en el último vídeo vimos dos formas
distintas de asignar estados de
oxidación la primera era haciéndolo de
la forma como lo hacíamos en química
general verdad memorizando algunas
reglas para asignar estados de oxidación
la segunda forma era la digamos la que
trabajamos en química orgánica donde
dibujamos la estructura de puntos y
después de considerar la electro
negatividad utilizamos esta fórmula
verdad que nos dice cómo calcular el
estado de oxidación el estado de
oxidación se calcula como tomando el
número de electrones de valencia que el
átomo tendría normalmente y de ahí
restamos el número de electrones de
valencia
que tenemos alrededor de la tomó después
de que consideramos la electro
negatividad y la segunda forma de
hacerlo es mucho mejor para para
moléculas de la química orgánica que son
muy complicadas así que vamos a ver
algunas de estas moléculas complicadas y
veamos si podemos asignar algunos
estados de oxidación así que vamos a
dibujar la estructura de puntos de una
llamada d
molécula llamada canal que consiste en
colocar un carbono atado con un enlace
doble a un oxígeno o más bien unido ok a
un oxígeno y aquí tenemos un hidrógeno
verdad ahí tenemos el hidrógeno y vamos
a ponerlo unido a otro carbono de hecho
a todo un grupo metilo verdad tenemos
aquí tres hidrógenos muy bien y solo
para poder hacer esto mucho más sencillo
vamos a poner todos los electrones muy
bien vamos a pensar cómo asignarle el
estado de oxidación a cada uno de estos
carbono si empezamos por ejemplo en este
de aquí en este de aquí para poder
asignar el estado de oxidación
necesitamos saber cuánto cuántos
electrones de valencia tendría un
carbono en digamos en condiciones
normales y esos son 4 electrones de
valencia ahora bien necesitamos que ver
cuántos electrones tendría después de
considerar la electro negatividad
vemos que el carbono es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno por lo tanto
este carbono va a tender a robar estos
electrones del hidrógeno y ahora nos
preguntamos qué es más electrón negativo
el carbono o el carbono bueno pues está
deje esta pregunta es medio extraña
porque realmente tienen la misma electro
negatividad así que van a compartir un
electrón en este carbono se queda con
este electrón mientras que este otro
carbono se queda con este otro electrón
así que si ahora contamos el número de
electrones que hay alrededor de nuestro
átomo de carbono podemos ver que son 2
467 por lo tanto su estado de oxidación
es de menos 3 muy bien vamos a ver qué
ocurre con el otro carbono pues nosotros
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el carbono así que el
oxígeno se va a robar estos 4 electrones
al carbono simplemente le queda este
y se roban los dos electrones del enlace
con el hidrógeno así que si queremos
calcular la electro negativa de perdón
el número de oxidación de este carbono
serían 4 electrones de valencia que
tendría normalmente menos 3 electrones
que se encuentran alrededor de él y esto
nos da un estado de oxidación de más 1
ahora vamos a dibujar algún producto es
decir vamos a tratar de ver alguna
especie de reacción química orgánica que
sea real y lo que tenemos aquí es el led
anal que puede convertirse en esta
molécula que voy a pintar aquí en la
derecha vamos a dibujar ácido acético y
el ácido acético es muy similar de hecho
tendremos nuestro carbono unido con este
oxígeno con un enlace doble vamos a
tener este mismo grupo metilo que este
mismo grupo metilo y recuerden que
estamos pintando todos los electrones
para que sea mucho más fácil calcular la
los números o los estados de oxidación
verdad y aquí en vez de estar unido a
este hidrógeno vamos a unirlo a un
a un oxígeno ok vamos a poner este
oxígeno por supuesto aquí bien podría
haber completado estos estos electrones
aquí lo mismo podemos hacer verdad y
este oxígeno vamos a ponerle sus dos
pares de electrones solitarios y este va
a estar unido finalmente a un hidrógeno
muy bien entonces ahí tienen ustedes el
ácido acético y el canal se convierte en
esta así que tenemos esta reacción y
otra vez queremos asignar los estados de
oxidación así que ya que hemos pintado
todos los electrones en esta molécula
vamos a tratar de calcularlo vamos a
asignar el estado de oxidación a
nuestros carbonos verdad y otra vez este
carbono que tenemos de este lado
satisface lamy el mismo arreglo verdad
entonces va a robarse estos dos se va a
robar estos dos estos dos va a compartir
uno con el otro carbono y por lo tanto
el número de oxidación de este carbono
será de 4 menos 7 que es
-3 en este realmente no hubo ningún
cambio ahora el cambio sustancial va a
ser en este carbono por lo siguiente
como el oxígeno es más electrón negativo
que el carbono se va a robar estos
electrones este carbono va a compartir
este electrón con este otro carbono pero
este ahora este oxígeno se va a robar
estos dos electrones así que si
consideramos esto el estado de oxidación
de este carbono será 4 - el número de
electrones alrededor de este carbono
después de la electro negatividad que es
1 así que el estado de oxidación es más
3 muy bien así que si hacemos un resumen
en el primer caso en el caso de la
izquierda teníamos que este carbono que
circule en rojo tenía un estado de
oxidación de más 1 mientras que en el
caso del ácido acético tenemos un estado
de oxidación de más 3 quiere decir que
tuvimos un incremento en el estado de
oxidación de este carbono y vimos en el
vídeo anterior que un incremento
el estado de oxidación significa que el
carbono se óxido en esta reacción así
que aquí tuvimos una reacción de
oxidación una reacción de oxidación que
hay así que sí estamos oxidando el
etanol vamos a obtener como producto el
ácido acético verdad y esta es una forma
muy padre muy poderosa perdón de
calcular el estado de oxidación de
moléculas de la química orgánica ok
ahora vamos a hacer una molécula más
complicada todavía más complicada y
vamos a ver cómo podemos aplicar algunas
cómo podemos aplicar algunas bueno no sé
de todo lo que hemos estado viendo esta
misma fórmula entonces vamos a poner
vamos a ponerlo aquí vamos a poner
digamos primero un anillo de 5 carbonos
ok vamos a poner un anillo de 5 carbonos
y lo tienen y de una vez vamos poniendo
nuestros electrones ahí tenemos un
anillo de 5 carbonos y simplemente nos
falta completar aquí este enlace pero
además vamos a poner algunos enlaces
dobles vamos a poner un enlace doble
aquí y otro enlace doble aquí ok y en
cada uno de estos carbonos vamos a poner
un hidrógeno que esté saliendo que y
vamos a poner un hidrógeno para que sea
más interesante esto y nada bueno
realmente es que no me estoy inventando
esta molécula esta molécula que estoy
poniendo aquí realmente tiene un nombre
y si yo le pongo aquí dos un un par de
electrones solitarios esta molécula de
aquí se llama el ciclo penta bien y lo
que es el ciclo penn está bien y lo y
ahora vamos a tratar de calcular
nuevamente los estados de oxidación de
cada uno de estos carbonos pero no sólo
eso vamos a compararlo con cómo calcular
la carga formal de cada uno de estos
carbonos porque son muy similares pero
pero en realidad son distintos muy bien
entonces con verde voy a calcular la
carga formal aquí vamos a poner la carga
formal
carga formal y por ejemplo empecemos con
este primer carbono que tenemos aquí
entonces la carga formal si se acuerdan
se calculaba como el número de
electrones de valencia que el átomo
tiene en condiciones normales - el
número de electrones que tiene
considerando bueno que están alrededor
pero considerando los enlaces justamente
como covalentes verdad entonces en el
caso del carbono tendremos cuatro y si
consideramos este caso cuántos
electrones tenemos alrededor tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 así que la carga formal de este
carbono es de menos 1 y justamente por
tener una carga negativa es que está
esta molécula es una unión verdad es una
unión ahora bien cuál sería o cómo
calcular y amos la
el estado de oxidación de este carbono
vamos a calcular el estado de oxidación
nuevamente por la fórmula que tenemos
acá arriba es el número de electrones de
valencia - el número de electrones que
hay alrededor de él después de
considerar la electro negatividad
considerando que fueran en la sesión y
cos verdad entonces tiene 4 electrones
de valencia - y ahora consideramos que
el carbono es más electro negativo que
el hidrógeno así que se roba estos
electrones verdad es igual de clement
déjenme hacerlo por arriba del verde se
roba estos dos electrones entre los
carbonos de la misma electrón
negatividad así que lo comparten lo
mismo pasa de este lado verdad entonces
tendremos cuántos electrones 1 2 3 4 5 6
verdad tendremos 6 y esto nos da un
resultado de menos 2 así que el estado
de oxidación de este carbono es menos 2
vamos a ver qué ocurre con los otros con
este carbono
y se roba los el electrón digamos de
aquí que se encuentra más cercano al
hidrógeno comparte estos con el otro
carbono porque son igual de electro
negativos y lo mismo ocurre con este
electrón así que el estado de oxidación
se calcula como 4 menos 1 2 3 4 5 quiere
decir que este carbono tiene un estado
de oxidación de menos 1 ahora bien
pasemos al siguiente si te das cuenta es
exactamente el mismo caso comparte estos
dos se roba estos electrones y comparte
este así que tenemos 4 menos 5 es menos
1 y lo mismo ocurre con este carbono
verdad tiene un
ya ya me equivoqué porque tenía que
robarse este de aquí verdad entonces
tiene menos 1 y lo mismo ocurre con este
otro carbono tiene un estado de
oxidación de menos 1 entonces fue la
misma situación para estos últimos 4 así
que como puedes darte cuenta tenemos
distintos estados de oxidación para
diferentes carbonos y en esta molécula y
muchas veces en lugar de de poner
estados de oxidación individuales
representados de esta forma veremos que
también podemos asignar estados de
oxidación que se llaman fraccionales así
que para el año del ciclo penta 10.000 o
sin comentario en ilo veremos qué un
estado fraccional de oxidación es menos
seis quintos ahora como calculamos eso
déjenme ponerlo de esta forma menos 6
quintos muy bien como calculamos esto
bueno de dónde viene este número
realmente esto es algo que confunde
muchos estudiantes justamente porque no
saben de dónde vienen y el estado
fraccional de oxidación de menos seis
quintos viene simplemente de asignar lo
siguiente calculamos todos los estados
de oxidación que hay en cada uno de
estos carbonos por ejemplo aquí está
menos dos aquí hay menos uno menos
1 - 1 y menos uno cuanto suman todos
estos tenemos menos 2 - 3 - 4 menos 5
menos 6 entonces este menos 6 justamente
viene de sumar todos los estados de
oxidación de estos carbonos ahora de
dónde viene este 5 pues justamente del
número de carbonos que tenemos en esta
molécula así que este número nos
representa mucha información de lo que
teníamos en esta molécula y esto
realmente era algo que siempre me
confundía cuando estudiaba yo la carrera
así que espero que esto haya aclarado
muchos digamos
sobre los estados fraccionarios de
oxidación así que utilizamos una forma
orgánica de asignar números de oxidación
para hacer nuestra vida mucho más fácil
sin es mucho más fácil para moléculas
complicadas